pour la police et et au ghana il en faut
davantage la police je les respecte
absolument pas est ce que vous pensez ou
de la police parlant chanson qu'est ce
que vous pensez vous de la police je
pense qu'elle est violente qui a des
problèmes dans la police aujourd'hui qui
font que les gens ils ont plus confiance
en eux
on n'a pas à les critiquer ou
il faut toujours donner plus de pouvoirs
oui ce que je pense de la police un rôle
qui est important néanmoins je pense
qu'elle n'a pas les moyens disons de
réussir sa mission
et ils ont bien du mérite voilà parce
que c'est très difficile pour eux qu'est
ce que vous leur reprochez aux policiers
est ce que vous leur reprochez vous à la
police pas grand chose
pas grand chose après je sais qu'ils ont
eu raison que chaque profession à ses
brebis galeuses mais moi personnellement
rien moi je suis étranger alors des fois
je sais embêté par la police
qu'est ce que vous leur reprochez aux
policiers alors d'être un peu trop sur
le faciès et un peu moins sur les actes
prévoir un comportement qui est pas
adapté
aux situations de de provoquer des
débordements
on dit qu'elle est violente est ce que
c'est votre avis kaboul - pas loin je
pense que justement elle pourrait très
bien être quand même plus énergiques
pour les trials on dit qu'elle est
violente est ce que c'est votre avis
clairement oui
clairement oui çà et là encore une fois
6 ça dépend des gens quoi moi ils ont
jamais été violent avec moi mais il
suffit que je me balade qu'un ami qui
n'a pas la bonne couleur de peau
justement pour que ça parte très très
vite en fait c'est pas mon avis du tout
du tout au contraire ils ne sont
peut-être pas assez dans certains cas
oui je pense qu'elle est bien tu sais ça
fait partie son rôle en france en tout
cas c'est un peu dommage qu'on tape sur
la police qu'on accuse la police de
violence alors que lé là pour faire son
métier
c'est pas tous les policiers qui sont
violents faut pas généraliser c'est
juste toute cette institutionnalisation
du truc ce système
cette fonction de la police qui est
systémique comment s'est organisée ça
c'est violent
[Musique]